we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a delightful caller thrilled
that she got vaccinated she's telling
random strangers listen to the joy in
her voice
i love you hi david this is laurel from
washington
yes and i was just watching a youtube
video about the guy who calls up and is
threatening you because
you gave vaccine advice no you didn't
anyhow i just called you to tell you
because i want to tell everybody
total strangers on the street have been
telling i've got both my doses
i am so happy so just my husband so does
my son
we are totally vaccinated house
and we are happy i am with you laurel i
am truly with you i wish more people
would do the exact same thing because we
know the path out of the pandemic
we see the data we see what's happening
in highly vaccinated countries we see
what's happening in the u.s
particularly in the most highly
vaccinated states there's no mystery
here folks
there's really no mystery all right so
let's uh let's do it
on today's bonus show we will talk about
the political aspect of rudy giuliani's
son running for governor of new york
particularly when rudy himself
is potentially in a very bad
investigative situation
with the walls closing in around him
what is that going to look like
number two bank of america will raise
its minimum wage to 25
per hour by 2025.
wow wow or is it we will talk about it
and also texas moving very quickly
no masks are required at just about
every texas
state facility anymore is this logical
based on the numbers
is this risky if yes for who
all of those questions and hopefully
some
answers on today's bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show two
ways
become a member at joinpacman.com or
become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow both ways you get
instant access to the bonus show it is a
good one today
and i hope to see you then